as vaccines are rolled out across the
country pent-up
travel demand is really turning into
reality over the weekend more americans
flew than at any point since the
pandemic began we saw las vegas was very
crowded over the weekend too
as errol bennett explains though health
officials are concerned
loosening restrictions could lead to
another infection spike
in san jose california kathy anderson
reunited with her daughter for the first
time
in a year i love you too
anderson is one of the millions of
americans who returned to the skies this
weekend
shattering pandemic travel records
increased demand prompted delta airlines
to temporarily open up middle seats
and americans domestic bookings are at
90 percent of pre-pandemic levels
it just seems like all of a sudden it's
a rush larry perez says he felt more
comfortable flying because he'd been
fully vaccinated
he's one of the 61 million americans
roughly one-fifth of u.s adults
who fall in that category we know for
vaccinated people it's reasonably safe
to do this
but among unvaccinated people it is not
yet and i'm worried that it's going to
lead to unfortunately more infections
and more hospitalizations
dr ashish jar says decreased testing
relaxation of public health measures
and new variants are now contributing to
the spread of covid
in several states it really is a race
right now between these variants that
have become widespread and are spreading
much more effectively and quickly
and how many people we can protect
through vaccines the variant
initially detected in the uk now
accounts for about 26 percent of covert
cases in the us
and this weekend officials announced a
new variant
initially identified in india was found
in the bay area
it's actually just made up of a couple
of other variants that we've seen
elsewhere the data so far suggests that
it may be more contagious
like the uk variant is now as scary as
that sounds josh says that the vaccines
do appear effective against the new
variants
and more americans are getting
vaccinated which is welcome news for the
travel industry
the sector really being battered by the
pandemic hotel
and leisure businesses added 280 000
jobs during the month of march
but the unemployment rate is still twice
the national average
at roughly 13 percent errol bonnett cbs
news newark new jersey